[Musique]
je vous invite à me rejoindre dans le
métro parisien
nous sommes en 1991
j'ai 23 ans je suis sur mon strapontin
je rentre chez moi il n'est pas encore
minuit après une soirée joyeuse avec des
amis une jeune femme rentre et
s'installe en face de moi
des pleurs
elle pleure beaucoup et ça me touche
sans être voyeur
ni me mêler de ce qui ne me regarde pas
g l'élan de lui venir en aide
dit lui qu'il va s'en sortir
une voix sortie de nulle part mme parle
il n'y a personne autour de moi et une
seconde fois
dit lui qu'il va s'en sortir et cette
fois ci la voix est plus puissante plus
insistantes je sais pas vraiment comment
réagir mon coeur s'accélère
soudain
j'ai une vision
celle de pompiers qui sont en train de
sortir un jeune homme d'une voiture
accidentée
je comprends pourquoi les tristes
je la regarde
mais tu gears est cette fois ci la voix
est tellement puissante elle m'a puis en
plus sur l'épaule je suis terrorisée la
porte du métro est ouverte je sors et je
remonte dans la rue
respirer
je culpabilise
je n'ai pas été capable de lui parler
ça recommence comme avant
suis je fou
j'avais pourtant mis un couvercle bien
faire mais vous savez comme celui d'une
cocotte minute
parce que ces visions était bien trop
présente à l'adolescence et que j'avais
le souhait d'avoir une vie normale
totalement normal
c'est pas facile d'être différent
l'adolescence
c'est même plutôt compliqué mais là je
suis en âge de trouver de l'aide
j'ai vite trouvé de l'aide j'ai vite
trouvé les bonnes personnes pour
m'accompagner et j'ai pu mettre en place
une forme de stabilité de vie dans
laquelle je pouvais ouvrir la porte à
ces phénomènes
uniquement quand je le souhaitais
une question me taraude est tout de même
à quoi bon
quelle est l'utilité de cela pourquoi
moi
oppressé personne
j'ai pu apprendre que je n'étais pas
seul et que nous étions même très
nombreux très nombreux à dialoguer avec
l'invisible mais à cette époque
personne n'en parle personne ça ne se
dit pas au grand jour
qu'importe mois leurs contacts je me
sens compris entendus
là j'ai pris conscience que
j'associais des valeurs négatives à
l'invisible à défaut par défaut
et que en plus j'avais un sentiment de
transgresser
un système de croyances d'établi
faut que je vous dise je suis de la
génération de shining poltergeist
amityville et tous ces films en format
tu es en moi une peur intense de tous
ces phénomènes
alors après il y aura ghost qui va enfin
amener des valeurs positives
merci hein et puis vous connaissez tous
la déferlante harry potter qui va ouvrir
les consciences de toute génération
confondue à travers le globe d'ailleurs
peut-être qu'il ya des moldy ce soir
dans la salle parmi nous vous savez
c'est comme ça qu'on appelle ceux qui ne
ressentent pas l'invisible
avec le temps
j'ai pu me rendre compte que nous étions
de plus en plus nombreux toutes
générations confondues
et pourtant j'avais toujours cru que
c'était un truc des huit grands mères
vous savez comme lire dans le marc de
café
comme utiliser une médaille religieuse
en ans pendu pour deviner le sexe de
l'enfant à venir et puis cet
entêtement à tout le temps parler de ces
superstitions vous savez comme ne passe
pas sous une échelle
attention si tu croises un chat noir
à l'âge de 27 ans j'ai temporairement
perdu la vue
et j'ai eu l'accord du corps médical
pour m'accompagner et pour avoir accès à
une méthode alternative
psychologue et énergéticiens
et en six mois ma vision est revenue
et le chirurgien a convenu que
l'opération n'était plus nécessaire
c'est cette expérience
qui m'a vraiment conduit à me former
al'approche énergétique corporelle
et oui le directeur marketing que
j'étais est devenu praticiens en
digitopuncture
manier l'énergie dans mes mains a du
sens
je me sens relié à un grand tout je me
sens dans une forme de connaissance
bienveillante
on peut donc vivre heureux avec ça
mais vous savez
cette ouverte conscience n'est pas
seulement réservé aux thérapeutes non
non ne pensait pas cela
les institutions les entreprises ont
toutes besoin de cette dimension pour
amener du mieux-être à l'humain du sens
et se sentir guider dans notre monde qui
est particulièrement mouvant
partout nous avons le besoin de nous
reconnecter à ce qui est encore
invisible pour beaucoup d'entre nous le
fait d'appartenir à un grand tous unis
le fait
d'intégrer que ce que je dis
ce que je pense
et ce que je fais a une répercussion sur
l'autre par un lien qui nous est devenu
imperceptible dans l'agitation de
l'immense village dans lequel nous
vivons et qu'il est bon pour nous de
rétablir
les lois jce l' équilibre de la nature
sont les mêmes que ceux qui régissent
l'équilibré du corps
et ses lois s'exprime à travers les
méridiens les méridiens des vaisseaux de
conscience
qui utilisent nos expériences
émotionnelles
pour oeuvrer à notre propre équilibre
physiologique
et psychologique
s'ils ont été
définies en asie il ya plus de 3000 ans
leur existence a récemment été validée
par des études scientifiques occidental
de plus les atomes qui nous composent
tous sont sur terre depuis sa création
c'est à dire qu'ils comportent en eux
qu'ils ont en eux la mémoire la mémoire
et l'information de tous les échanges
chimiques et énergétiques qui ont eu
lieu à travers le temps
et la science quantique nous confirme
aussi que tous ces atomes sentons dial
sont en dialogue perpétuelle même à très
longue distance
c'est à dire qu'en fait nous vivons dans
une forme de plasma de conscience un
plasma d'information dans lequel chaque
être est interconnecté à l'autre et dans
lequel il a son importance
je crois beaucoup en cette connexion
pour mettre en place un monde plus juste
plus humain
plus sensibles
et je suis heureux de constater que de
plus en plus de personnes ayant des
responsabilités élevées en entreprise
applique cette ouverture dans leur
travail au quotidien
regardez vos collègues regardez votre
patron peut être s'ils ont des cristaux
sur leur bureau au poignet
s'ils ont des phrases ou des images
inspirante au mur et s'il arrive à
opposer une vision totalement intuitive
à une étude cartésienne alors là
peut-être que vous pourriez les regarder
sous un nouvel angle
soyez
émotion
elle transforme les mouvements
extérieurs du corps en réaction physico
chimiques à l'intérieur de nos corps
pour nous aider à mettre en oeuvre la
juste posture et le juste mouvement pour
faire face aux expériences que nous
vivons
ayez confiance en vos l'intelligence de
vos cellules
votre corps
c'est votre gps
et il ne se trompe pas
il sait qui vous êtes
il sait où il est bon pour vous d'aller
et pour cela il sait aussi ce qu'il est
bon pour vous de mettre en mouvement
soyez attentif et à l'écouté de votre
ressenti
nous parlions du monde professionnel
l'intelligence émotionnelle est
aujourd'hui
un élément majeur du processus de
recrutement
parce que on peut plus facilement
acquérir des compétences techniques que
avoir d'emblée la juste position
relationnelles ou managériale
et cela on devrait vraiment l'aborder
depuis l'école et ça aurait une
répercussion tellement positive sur les
relations humaines et sur notre position
à chacun dans la société
le sixième sens
ne se cache plus
c'est même un atout
laissez-le exprimer
parce qu'enfant
vous le faisiez naturellement
je vous invite à
me suivre dans le métro parisien
imaginons qu'une jeune femme rentrait
viennent s'asseoir ici sur ce strapontin
devant vous
imaginons qu'elle pleure
qu'elle pleure beaucoup
si cela vous touche
alors s'il vous plaît suivez votre
addition
parce que l'invisible
mesdames
messieurs
ce n'est que de l'amour
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]